i think the last two days have been
really challenging for me because i i
felt like
after winning against rafa feeling was
like almost that the tournament is done
because most of the times when we meet
it's in the finals of the events
uh this time it was semi-final and
obviously a great battle of over four
hours
i needed to regroup i needed to recharge
the batteries and try to
come out on the court against titibus
that was informed and performed my best
you know it wasn't easy at all
considering you know what i've been
through in the semi-finals and it took a
lot out of me i think emotionally
physically and and uh and mentally as
well
after a bit of a slower start for me i i
found my groove i found my rhythm i kind
of adjusted also to conditions they were
quite different from semi-finals and
after
after a very good start in the third set
there was no looking back you know i
found
my game and i managed to to kind of
start to read his game and finish off
the match in in the best possible style
i mean coming back from two sets down i
don't think i've ever done that in in
the finals of a slam so it's it makes
this this win extra special well paris
uh
has been
a very particular
place for me in my career because i've
tried so many times to win roland garros
and it was the only grand slam that i
never won and
had missing until 2016.
i can recall the
feelings that i had on the court when i
won that match uh in 2016 it was a i
think most of all a huge relief because
there was so much
expectations and pressure being built
from my own self and then of course
everyone else around me
that i i have to win it you know and
after losing two three finals and uh
ever since then you know
i was always kind of coming back to
paris hoping that i can do it again you
know at least before before i end my
career not it's not like my end is
anywhere near i'm not thinking about it
but i just
felt like to win a roland garros for me
was probably the biggest task of of any
other slam because of rafa and just
because of surface and i think
the game itself so to win it again at
this at this age at this stage of my
career is
something very remarkable i'm very
grateful and very very thrilled with
that achievement